paris quartier du panthéon petite soirée
au salon del libro librairie spécialisée
dans la littérature hispanique jesús
figa exilés cubains est venu témoigner
de la répression castriste un quotidien
de dissidents politiques banni de son
pays un homme qui pourtant n'a rien
perdu de sa joie de vivre ni son cigare
ce soir il est venu encourager son
compagnon d'armes l'écrivain
universitaire jacobo machover qui
présente son dernier hommage cuba
l'aveuglément coupable l'occasion de
partager quelques anecdotes
[Musique]
la
l'apparition
[Musique]
jacobo machover lui vit en france depuis
30 ans pour résoudre c'est son ami les
années ont passé mais la révolte
demeurent la relative ouverture
politique est la libéralisation
économique annoncée récemment par le
gouvernement cubain ne sont qu'un leurre
[Musique]
cuba décembre 1959 les révolutionnaires
entrent à la havane à leur tête fidel
castro il prend le pouvoir et condamne
le dictateur batista à l'exil
mais les cubains déchante vite la
révolution devient communiste et un
régime de fer et ras le peuple depuis 50
ans toute opposition politique est
sévèrement réprimée en 1989 la chute du
grand frère soviétique la grave la
situation économique entre misère et
persécutions des milliers de cubains
sont condamnés à l'exil
un exil qui a aussi touché jesús ce soir
il vient rejoindre son ami jacobo
le premier immeuble parisienne que ie
connu une fois que j'arrivais il ya 80
en france et qui s'étire comme un
sauveur ou amis
jesús et jacobo anim'ensemble
l'association combat libre est l'objet
de la visite déterminer la réaction
officielle de l'association al annonce
du prix sakharov un prix décerné par la
communauté européenne au dissident
cubain guillermo farinas
mais les préoccupations personnelles de
jesús reprennent vite le dessus à cuba
rhésus était journaliste ces articles
anti castro l'ont obligé à quitter le
pays en 2007 et le risque et 20 ans de
prison
mais les autorités de la havane n'ont
pas autorisé sa femme et sa fille âgée
de 6 ans à le suivre résultat il n'a pas
revu sa famille depuis quatre ans
je pense que la sauce a beaucoup de
pudeur parce que
j'ai vécu cela de très près
mais bon on essaye de passe
c'est cette à leytron là dessus parce
que sinon c'est trop difficile à vivre
ici et vont la séparation
d'avec sa femme et sa fille c'est c'est
quelque chose qui est très lourd et
jalouse
mais c'est toujours à la tombée de la
nuit que la nostalgie est rare et sousse
et cuba lui semble alors bien loin
[Musique]
il ya huit ans m il ya de la fenêtre de
ma chambre pour
les servir et ses îles samoa et à chaque
fois ça m'est fait des souvenirs comment
y arriver il ya peut-être avions-nous
ballet à cuba ce que ça m'arrivera
mais voilà on assume efforts continus
en bio sahara china
aujourd'hui jesús retrouve eduardo la
mort à un réalisateur cubain installé à
paris après 30 ans passés loin des siens
eduardo a réussi à rentrer au pays en
2006 et a filmé les retrouvailles avec
sa famille c'est l'objet de son
documentaire intitulé cuba l'art de la
patience
[Musique]
ensemble ils doivent regarder le film
d'eduardo qui a retrouvé des membres de
sa famille dans le plus grand besoin son
triste constat la situation économique
dramatique du pays
ces
îles sont de la famille mais c'est une
famille
s'est soldée par un doux faire de mon
père
pour la ville
il est
hélas mso l'axé l'émissaire de voir
comment ces deux petits dieux survivre
seul c'est difficile à croire qu'un pays
avec les difficultés qu'on aime et qu'il
a eu à cuba a survécu c'est une section
de ces immigrés qui soutiennent un
coquet pas l'économie cubaine assez pour
nos deux exilés cubains n'est pas à la
fin d'un cycle le castrisme se porte
encore bien la récente décision de
supprimer plus de cinq cent mille
emplois dans le secteur public d'ici à
mars 2011 dans le cadre d'un processus
de rationalisation ne sont pour eux que
poudre aux yeux
[Musique]
v gt ou s'ouvrir au monde l'avenir de
cuba semble bien trouble en attendant
comme chaque semaine entre et sousse
tente de joindre sa famille ce soir
personne ne répondra